küsten befestigungen mit einer
dramatischen geschichte aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg auf dieser seite des
wellenbrecher das finden wir vielleicht
die antwort auf die frage um was es sich
hier handelt deswegen will ich da rein
ein riesiger komplex mit einer brisanten
vergangenheit
[Musik]
das führte zu einer ausbreitung und
verfestigung der sklaverei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und eine insel festung mit einem dunklen
geheimnis
sie zerstörten häuser und vernichteten
akten niemand sollte wissen was passiert
ist
zerfallene bauten ruinen aus vergangener
zeit einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur
noch schatten ihrer selbst seit ihre
geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
in der nähe der insel portland vor der
englischen südküste
liegt ein ort mit einer dramatischen
vergangenheit
[Musik]
ein richtiges ungetüm massiv gebaut mit
metall verkleidet mit allen möglichen
anbauten obendrauf und an den seiten
ein wirklich ungewöhnliches bauwerk es
hat nicht nur einem zweck gedient es
entwickelte sich im laufe eines
jahrhunderts immer weiter
gibt es eine verbindung zu einem
gefängnis auf portland auf den ersten
blick finden wir keine hinweise
was war da draußen wozu der abstand vom
festland
[Musik]
ein total klaustrophobischer ort
praktisch uneinnehmbar und gleichzeitig
ausbruchsicher
auch die küste hier ist übersät mit
relikten aus der vergangenheit
[Musik]
in der umgebung stehen noch einige
andere gebäude
sie sind teil eines langfristigen groß
angelegten bauprojekts
in unterschiedlichen phasen der
geschichte hat sich da eine menge
abgespielt aber wie das alles
zusammenhängt ist erstmal rätselhaft was
also verbirgt sich in dem kreisrunden
gemäuer wozu wurde es gebaut
während des zweiten weltkriegs kamen
tausende us-soldaten hierher um sich auf
die entscheidende schlacht gegen nazi
deutschland vorzubereiten
doch nicht alle bauwerke hier stehen
damit in zusammenhang
robben ist nach portland gereist um die
anlage genauer anzusehen
[Musik]
ich bin schon auf einige ruinen gestoßen
die über die ganze insel verteilt sind
es scheint als warte hinter jeder ecke
die nächste
einige sind noch gut erhalten andere
sehen aus als könnten sie jeden moment
einstürzen
bella hat eine sondergenehmigung
bekommen er darf sich alles aus nächster
nähe ansehen
durch die fenster sieht man lampen an
den decken es muss also irgendwann strom
gegeben haben
ein alter ofen der vor sich hin rostet
er war vermutlich zum heizen aber
das eine gebäude aus dem wir schließen
könnten wozu dass sie alles gut war das
gibt es nicht
aber eine stelle stich doch heraus
das sieht schon anders aus erst dachte
ich noch eine alte ruine aber der
grundriss ist ganz anders
ok
an der runden form und der erhöhten
plattform in der mitte sieht man dass
das eine geschützstellung war
aber nicht bloß irgendein geschützt
schauen sie sich die dimensionen an das
muss ein riesen ding gewesen sein
während des zweiten weltkriegs wimmelt
es hier vor soldaten
die aufmerksamkeit der truppe ist aufs
meer gerichtet
den hat sie schicken ihre schnellboote
bis an die küste u-boote patroullierten
in der gegend die ganze situation hier
war extrem angespannt
der angriff kann jederzeit kommen die
deutsche kriegsmarine hat die britischen
küsten stellungen im visier
in den häfen bereiten sich die schiffe
auf die große schlacht vor die die wende
im krieg bringen soll
[Musik]
das waren hunderte von schiffen dicht an
dicht überall wo platz war
sie alle bereiten sich vor auf die
entscheidende phase des kriegs in
westeuropa
[Musik]
die weit verstreuten ruinen verraten
heute kaum noch etwas von der rolle die
sie damals gespielt haben
rob bell ist noch von einem anderen
aspekt fasziniert einige der bauwerke
stammen offenbar aus einer anderen zeit
die mauern da oben auf der klippe machen
mich neugierig sieht aus als hätten sie
schon lange vor dem zweiten weltkrieg
dort gestanden
die frage ist wo zu waren all die
älteren gebäude
und haben sie auch dazu beigetragen dass
dieses gebiet im zweiten weltkrieg so
wichtig wurde
auf der suche nach antworten fährt raus
zum wellenbrecher draußen vor dem hafen
ich habe mir jetzt schon einige der
verlassenen gebäude hier angeschaut
das da habe ich bis jetzt nur von weitem
gesehen ich habe den verdacht dass ich
dort den entscheidenden hinweis finden
werde
es sieht aus wie ein altes gefängnis
dass einiges abbekommen hat
schwer zu sagen ob die zugemauerten
fenster die leute vom rhein oder vom
rauskommen abhalten sollten
war es eine quarantäne station oder doch
ein gefängnis warum so weit weg vom
festland
sehen sie da unten das ist der
entscheidende hinweis
das sind riesige kanonen
ich habe gehört dass es definitiv eine
verbindung zwischen diesem ort und dem
gefängnis auf der insel geben soll
aus der artillerie hier schließe ich
dass das eine art vorwahl worin bestand
die verbindung zum gefängnis ich hoffe
wir finden drin mehr hinweise
bell wird von gordon report unterstützt
einem örtlichen meeres archäologen genau
wie bell war er noch nie in dem vor
zum ersten mal hat er die gelegenheit es
sich von innen anzuschauen
[Musik]
wow echt beeindruckend ich würde gern
was klären können sie mir sagen worin
genau die verbindung zu dem gefängnis
bestand
die gefängnisse wurden gebaut um
arbeitskräfte für den nahegelegenen
steinbruch zu haben die gefangenen
mussten das baumaterial für den
wellenbrecher beschaffen nach
norden süden und westen ist das vor
durch die natürlichen bedingungen
abgesichert gefahr droht nur von osten
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
erkennen die verantwortlichen die gefahr
sie beschließen einen wellenbrecher zu
bauen nach fertigstellung ist er über
zweieinhalb kilometer lang
[Musik]
ein gewaltiges projekt sie ließen die
häftlinge im steinbruch dafür schuften
dabei entstanden die riesigen felsblöcke
die jetzt in gerader linie ins meer
hinaus führen
damals ist das der größte künstlich
angelegte hafen der welt
der wellenbrecher schutz die nicht nur
vor angriffen sondern auch vor stürmen
da hinten scheint ein bisschen licht
rein kommt dass durch die zugemauerten
fenster früher waren sie noch offen oder
waren abgedeckt wenn sie nicht gebraucht
wurden
durch diese fenster feuerten die kanonen
aufs meer die kanonen die ich unten im
wasser gesehen hat die so aussehen als
wären sie da einfach runter geschmissen
worden das sind aber nur teile davon sie
gehören zu den ersten in den 1800 70er
jahren hier stationiert wurden
um den hafen zu verteidigen werden 14
solcher kanonen in gleichmäßigem abstand
rund um das vor stationiert aber wer war
eigentlich der feind
[Musik]
worin lag die bedrohung wozu brauchen
sie das vor überhaupt
die franzosen befestigten damals ihre
küste und investierten im großen stil in
ihre marine
das wurde als bedrohung wahrgenommen
großbritannien und frankreich waren ewig
verzeichnet obwohl damals gerade frieden
herrschte gab es die angst dass wieder
krieg ausbrechen könnte
england beschließt seine küste zu
befestigen
[Musik]
der bau war zweckmäßig und gut
durchdacht mit tunneln und durchgänge
jeder mit einer speziellen funktionen
jetzt geht's richtig runter sehen sie
sich das an die durchgerosteten geländer
das ist der erste bauabschnitt von
portlands befestigungsanlage
die kriegstechnik entwickelt sich immer
weiter und damit wachsen die
anforderungen an das vor dabei kommt es
auf jeden zentimeter an
[Musik]
hier wurde die munition aufbewahrt wir
nehmen uns das ist eine der hebe züge
da kamen die granaten rhein und die
zünder und dann wurden sie hochgezogen
warum wurde die munition getrennt von
den kanonen aufbewahrt
um sie vor möglichen treffern zu
schützen
ein treffer munitionslager hätte eine
katastrophe ausgelöst
der wellenbrecher ist der zentrale
baustein des verteidigungskonzept aber
nicht der einzige
weitere anlagen werden gebaut ein
riesiges projekt
als endlich alles fertig ist folgt
allerdings ernüchterung
[Musik]
um die jahrhundertwende entwickelte sich
die militärtechnologie rasant weiter
kaum hattest du etwas gebaut war es
schon wieder überholt
diese anlagen wurden als reaktion auf
die französische bedrohung errichtet das
dauerte mehrere jahrzehnte als sie
fertig waren waren sie beinahe peinlich
denn die bedrohung existiert nicht mehr
wie kommt es dann dass das relikt aus
dem 19 jahrhundert so eine zentrale
rolle im zweiten weltkrieg spielt
auf dem dach des fonds gibt es hinweise
das hier sieht wie ein geschützturm aus
genau so einen gibt es da hinten
allerdings wirkt er viel moderner als im
vor weiter unten
stimmt das vor wurde in den 1800 70er
jahren gebaut aber ständig ausgebaut es
gab viele verschiedene bauabschnitte bis
zum zweiten weltkrieg damals stand auf
einer plattform jedes letzte aktive
geschützt das bo fonds geschützt
hitlers truppen über rollen in
sogenannten blitzkrieg deutschlands
westlichen nachbarn
bis zur englischen südküste ist es nicht
mehr weit
im hafen gabes einige ziele für
bombenangriffe deswegen waren hier
geschütze in stellung die mündungen in
den himmel gerichtet die befestigungen
kann man heute noch sehen sie dienten
zur flugabwehr zum schutz des hafens
aber wie soll die veraltete anlage dem
scheinbar unvermeidlichen deutschen
angriff stand halten
zurück auf dem festland inspiziert
roppel jetzt die alte stellung des black
nur fort
[Musik]
ich bin hier oben auf den klippen an der
westseite von portland eine weitere
riesige geschützstellung
eine ganze reihe davon bildeten entlang
der südküste eine starke
verteidigungslinie
zwischen dem ende des 19 jahrhunderts
und dem beginn des zweiten weltkriegs
werden der hafen um die umliegenden
anlagen ständig modernisiert und
verstärkt der wellenbrecher wird
verlängert artillerie stellungen kommen
hinzu und entlang der küste entstehen
weitere befestigungen
wie burton aus der viktorianischen
epoche und aus dem ersten weltkrieg
wurden verstärkt um besser gegen die
deutsche bedrohung gewappnet zu sein man
rechnete jeden moment mit einem angriff
während der luftschlacht um england im
sommer 1940 war portland ein wichtiges
ziel für die luftwaffe einige schiffe im
hafen wurden versenkt die deutschen
bomber flogen bei tag und bei nacht
angriffe auf portland
der verlängerte wellenbrecher und die
modernisierten befestigungen aber halten
den angriff stand
wir sehen hier die evolution eines
standorts von mitte des 19 bis mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
[Musik]
anstatt die alten bauten abzureißen
wurden sie in die neuen integriert
im juni 1944 kommt endlich die schlacht
auf die portland so lange gewartet hat
aber es geht dabei nicht um verteidigung
sondern um angriff
denn es sind keine deutschen die hier
landen sondern amerikaner
portland soll eine wichtige rolle bei
der größten invasion der geschichte
spielen dem d day
dieser ort brachte von anfang an alles
notwendige mit auf der einen seite
bildet der strand eine natürliche
barriere auf der anderen seite gibt es
den steinbruch mit den felsen für den
wellenbrecher
dazu kamen die starken
verteidigungsanlagen mit all den
modernisierungen und erweiterungen
portland hatte die entsprechende
infrastruktur für die bevorstehende
aufgabe
ein großer teil der rund 1000 schiffe
die als teil der taskforce runde im
kanal überqueren startet in portland
ziel ist omaha beach in der von
deutschland besetzten normandie
tausende soldaten gingen hier an bord
und erwarteten den angriffsbefehl
kaum vorstellbar was sie in diesen
augenblicken empfunden haben müssen
hier waren sie noch ein relativer
sicherheit in einem gut verteidigten
hafen das war ja eigentlich eine
verteidigungsanlage aber es war auch ein
ideales sprungbrett für den die idee
im westen war das der entscheidende tag
des zweiten weltkriegs wenn die
alliierten die wehrmacht auf dem
europäischen kontinent direkt angreifen
konnten würden sie das naziregime
irgendwann stürzen
als der befehl schließlich kam am 6 juni
1944 fuhren die schiffe aus dem hafen
vorbei an den vorster drüben es war eine
gezeigten bände wie eisenhower sagte die
freien männer der welt marschierten
gemeinsam zum sieg
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg verlieren die
hafen befestigungen schnell an bedeutung
die geschütze werden abgebaut dann wird
die anlage geschlossen
heute diente hafen hauptsächlich dem
handel und für freizeitaktivitäten
aber die bauten die einst einen
wichtigen anteil an der befreiung
europas hatten sind erhalten geblieben
im herzen der amerikanischen südstaaten
an den ufern des oder krieg stoßen wir
auf die überreste eines
geschichtsträchtigen bauwerks
[Musik]
diese anlage liegt in der nähe von
montgomery alabama sie wirkt völlig fehl
am platz am meisten fallen die industrie
gebäude auf sie erinnern eher an eine
industriestadt in nordengland
es ist wirklich schwer zu sagen wie
diese gebäude genutzt worden
der gebäudekomplex ist groß und das
gelände weitläufig hier muss etwas
bedeuten bis produziert worden sein ein
tunnel führt zum ufer hinunter man sieht
wie viel kraft die strömung hat
der fluss muss eine rolle für diese
anlage gespielt haben
drinnen finden wir kaum noch spuren
[Musik]
es ist wie ausgestorben
kaum vorstellbar dass hier früher
maschinenlärm und betriebsamkeit
herrschte
die hallen sind leer trotzdem ist klar
dass hier früher in großem stil
produziert wurde jetzt sind da nur noch
büroräume verwaiste schreibtische
verstreutes papier
als wäre alles plötzlich evakuiert
worden
auf dem hügel oberhalb der anlage finden
wir hinweise
da ist ein friedhof irgendwie ist er
unheimlich
eines der gräber ist mit zwei flaggen
der konföderierten geschmückt
die schlagen deuten auf einen
zusammenhang mit dem amerikanischen
bürgerkrieg der das land zerrissen hat
was also wurde hier hergestellt und
worin besteht die verbindung zum
bürgerkrieg
[Musik]
rottweil ist historikerin in alabama sie
setzt sich für den erhalt des
gebäudekomplexes ein der so etwas ist
wie ein fenster in die vergangenheit
kannst du nicht mehr die geschichte der
menschen erzählen die dort gelebt und
gearbeitet haben
der mann hinter dem ganzen ist eine
wichtige figur in der geschichte der
südstaaten
was er hier herstellte half dabei die
usa zur größten volkswirtschaft der welt
zu machen aber es spaltete auch das land
denn york red kam in den dreißiger
jahren des 19 jahrhunderts von new
hampshire nach alabama er war einer der
ersten großindustriellen des südens
damals war der barmer praktisch noch
wildnis
wollte den leuten arbeit geben ihn zu
einem besseren leben verhelfen
er war ein visionär
er baut also eine fabrik wie sie die
leute in alabama noch nie gesehen haben
dort produziert er eine der wichtigsten
maschinen des frühen 19ten jahrhunderts
vermutlich ahnt daniel brett nicht
welches vermögen her mit seiner maschine
machen und welches unheil sie anrichten
wird
ursprünglich kam craig nur nach alabama
green ihre maschinen zu bauen und zu
vertreiben
wegen des tempos mit dem sie die fasern
von den samen trennte revolutionierte
die clean air maschine den baumwollanbau
des bildes selben zeit in der man per
hand ein pfund baumwolle verarbeitet
schafft die maschine 50 pfund
ein mann namens aila hat die maschine
bereits 40 jahre zuvor entwickelt doch
erst pratt erkennt ihre bedeutung
angesichts eines rasant wachsenden markt
ließ sich die maschine 1794 patentieren
viel hat er damit nicht verdient und das
obwohl baumwolle in den usa bis mitte
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts zum
exportartikel nummer eins wurde
platz unternehmen wächst und wächst
unter anderem verkaufte er nach
frankreich und russland
das zeigt warum er als einer der ersten
großen industriellen des südens gilt
brad ist enorm erfolgreich er lässt ein
komplettes dorf nach dem vorbild seiner
heimatstadt in new hampshire baum um
dort seine angestellten unterzubringen
überall im nach ihm benannten brad will
ist seine handschrift zu erkennen
es war durch und durch pro stadt die
meisten leute arbeiteten in seinen
fabriken gingen in die kirchen die er
gebaut hatte besuchten die schulen die
er finanziert hatte
red will war ein vorbild für viele
andere städte im süden
hatte eine klare vision für brad will
alles was er hier erschuf sollte
irgendwie an ewing und erinnern
in brad will sorgen krätz unternehmen
für jobs und wachsendem wohlstand
anderswo haben sie den gegenteiligen
effekt auf das leben der menschen
die in ihr maschine war zwar eine
moderne erfindung
ironischerweise führte sie aber dazu
dass der bedarf nach einer alten und
traditionellen form der arbeit wuchs der
sklavenarbeit
früher wurden die baumwollfasern per
hand von den samen getrennt jetzt
beschleunigt die maschine den prozess
mehr baumwolle wird gebraucht auf den
feldern fällt mehr arbeit an und diese
arbeit wird von sklaven verrichtet
baumwolle ist eine pflanze die den boden
nicht so stark aus glaubt de grigny
maschine beschleunigte die verarbeitung
und ermöglichte so die verbreitung der
sklaverei in den südstaaten
france maschine revolutionierte nicht
nur die sklaverei in den usa sie
verfestigte sie
denn ihre pretzsch ist überzeugter
christ der widerspruch zwischen seinen
religiösen überzeugungen und seine rolle
als sklavenhalter ist ihm bewusst
der bevorstehende bürgerkrieg stürzt ihn
in ein dilemma dass er nicht länger
ignorieren kann
auf dem familien friedhof oberhalb der
fabrik wird klar für welche seite er
sich schließlich entscheidet
er ist ein ort stadler im süden aus
alter loyalität gegenüber der union
spricht er sich zunächst gegen die
abspaltung aus später schlägt er sich
aber doch auf die seite der südstaaten
es gab sogar eine militäreinheit die
nach ihm benannt wurde die bread
wildragout die er mit waffen versorgt er
lieferte auch den stoff für die
uniformen der konfigurierten
der krieg wird hauptsächlich auf dem
gebiet der südstaaten ausgetragen
irgendwann erreicht er auch brad will
[Musik]
und daniel kretz lebenswerk gerät in
gefahr
der world trade einheiten der
nordstaaten waren in dieser gegend
unterwegs aber wir wissen bis heute
nicht wieso sie pretz fabrik verschonten
vielleicht retteten ihn seine guten
beziehungen
selbst
was immer der grund ist trotz fabrik
übersteht den krieg unbeschadet
in finanzieller hinsicht kommt er jedoch
nicht so glimpflich davon
viele seiner arbeiter und vor allem
seine vertriebs leute waren eingezogen
worden
es gab kriegs blockaden die den export
der maschinen verhinderten das hatte
große auswirkungen auf sein geschäft
das schlimmste war dass er in
kriegsanleihen bezahlt wurde einer
währung der konföderierten die bald
wertlos war
der krieg kann dann ja brad teuer zu
stehen einige historiker denken dass er
eine halbe million dollar verlor und
praktisch ruiniert war
nach dem bürgerkrieg sind die aussichten
für pretz unternehmen düster
welche chancen hat er in den zeiten des
wiederaufbaus und was soll aus seiner
stadt werden
es dauert eine ganze weile bis die
produktion wieder anlief
aber brad war entschlossen es zu
schaffen und am ende gelang ihm das auch
dort nicht nur sein eigenes geschäft
wieder auf er unterstützt damit die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung in ganz
alabama
davon profitieren auch menschen wie
ernie adwords der noch bis weit ins 20
jahrhundert hier arbeitet
zu unseren besten zeiten als baumwolle
noch spitzenpreise erzielte und sich die
maschinen entsprechend verkauften haben
wir hier im drei schicht system
gearbeitet aber
die erfolgsgeschichte endet nach mehr
als 150 jahren herrscht ab 2009
plötzlich ruhe in den produktionshallen
auf dem internationalen markt ist das
unternehmen nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig
[Musik]
am meisten fehlen mir die kolleginnen
und kollegen die fabrik ist in einem
wirklich traurigen zustand es wäre schön
wenn es hier irgendwann weiterginge
[Musik]
jetzt kämpfen die einheimischen für den
erhalt des geschichtsträchtigen
komplexes aber die zukunft ist ungewiss
wahrscheinlich entstehen hier
appartements und büroflächen das ist
immer noch besser als sein kompletter
abriss denn so bleiben wenigstens die
charakteristische architektur und das
historische flair erhalten hoffentlich
[Musik]
hinüber zum mittelmeer zu insel kreta
in einer bucht liegt ein kleines ein
land mit dramatische geschichte
so eine wunderschöne insel das reinste
paradies aber
wenn du näher kommst siehst du plötzlich
diese mächtigen mauern
jetzt wird klar das ist eine festung und
was für eine
vielleicht war es eine
verteidigungsanlage vielleicht aber auch
ein gefängnis
hinter den mauern führen tunnel und
schmale wege zu einer ansammlung
zerstört der steinhäuser
er lebte hier und was hatten sie mit den
leuten auf der hauptinsel zu tun
früher war es verboten die insel zu
besuchen ich konnte gar nicht schnell
genug wieder runterkommen
inzwischen hat die insel berühmtheit
erlangt aber die wahrheit ist kaum
bekannt
wenn man sie dann erfährt wird klar was
die regierung alles vertuschen wollte
was ist das geheimnis dieses ortes und
warum stritt die griechische regierung
alles so hartnäckig ab
die imposanten mauern wurden im 16
jahrhundert von den venezianern
errichtet sie gehörten zu einer festung
später bekamen sie eine etwas andere
funktion
bis circa 1900 bewohnten türken die
insel um sie zu vertreiben wurde
beschlossen leprakranke her zu bringen
das sollte die türken verscheuchen
danach beschloss ein dänischer arzt auf
der insel ein medizinisches experiment
durchzuführen
dieser dänische arzt war der
einflussreiche edward elgars
wie alle anderen damals auch war er
davon überzeugt dass lepra ansteckend
sei man müsse nur alle leprapatienten
auf die insel bringen wenn sie zehn oder
zwanzig jahre später gestorben wären sei
die lepra im ganzen land ausgerottet
das ist spina longa was hier vor sich
ging wurde später vertuscht
auf der insel wurden leprakranke
ausgesetzt
wenn du eingesperrt bist kann selbst der
schönste ort zum horror werden
wie konnte dieses inselparadies zu einem
albtraum ort werden und warum wollten
die behörden alles vertuschen
die kranken trugen glöckchen um den hals
um die gesunden zu warnen wenn sie auf
die insel kamen erwartete sie ein
eindrücklicher empfangen das tor für die
leprakranken hatte den spitznamen dante
store mit bezug auf dantes inferno
angeblich gab es eine frau die es nicht
ertragen konnte von ihrem erkrankten
mann getrennt zu sein der auf die insel
deportiert worden war
also indizierte sie sich sein blut um
sich anzustecken
die kranken leben hier unter
unmenschlichen bedingungen
es war um 1910 als bei einer jungen frau
kurz vor ihrer hochzeit lepra
diagnostiziert wurde sie wurde hierher
verschleppt das leben hier war damals
extrem hart
schon kurz nach der ankunft wurde sie
vergewaltigt
danach stieg sie auf den turm und sprang
sie wollte lieber tot sein als auf
dieser insel zu leben so schrecklich war
es dort
der dänische arzt elias tut wenig um das
leid der kranken zu den dann er
behandelt sie nicht und gibt ihnen auch
keine medikamente er schirmt die lepra
kolonie sogar von nachrichten über neue
mögliche heilmittel ab
wer hier lebte war auf sich allein
gestellt jeder kümmerte sich nur um sich
auch wenn das auf kosten anderer ging
[Musik]
was wurde aus den lepra kantner als
autor und anthropologe movie is born
1968 zum ersten mal nach china london
kommt ist die insel keine lepra kolonie
mir und für die öffentlichkeit
geschlossen er beschließt ihre dunkle
vergangenheit an die öffentlichkeit zu
bringen
als ich auf kreta war und
nachforschungen anstellte stieß sich in
den archiven immer wieder auf den namen
remondis
bonn beschließt epaminondas remondis zu
suchen in einem labor sowie um in athen
einem haus in dem leprakranke isoliert
werden findet er ihn schließlich und
remondis ist bereit das geheimnis der
schreckens insel zu lüften er beginnt
mit seiner eigenen geschichte
er erkrankte im alter von zwölf jahren
seine familie versteckte ihn bei seinem
bruder in athen um ihn vor der
deportation zu bewahren in der großen
stadt konnte er leichter untertauchen
er wechselte häufig die schulen damit
seine erkrankung nicht erkannt wurde er
machte seinen abschluss und studierte
sogar jura
aber eines tages wurde sein geheimnis
entdeckt
1936 kommt er auf die insel und bringt
einiges in bewegung
[Musik]
er war einer der wenigen leprakranken
die lesen und schreiben konnten die
anderen machten ihn zu ihrem anführer
und er kämpfte für bessere
lebensbedingungen
er gründete die bruderschaft der kranken
[Musik]
als erstes regelten sie ihr
zusammenleben sie fegten die wege
strichen die häuser an organisierten
spiele und konzerte
anschließend begann re montag ist briefe
nach draußen zu schreiben er versuchte
die öffentlichkeit über die krankheit
aufzuklären und bessere
lebensbedingungen und bessere therapien
für die menschen in diesem de facto
gefängnis zu erreichen
riemann drugs und seine bruderschaft
sind außerdem fest entschlossen die
insel zu verlassen und zu ihren familien
zurückzukehren
de/re las allerdings gefällt das alles
gar nicht
der direktor der lepra kolonie versuchte
all dem ein ende zu setzen er versuchte
die bewohner einzuschüchtern und verbot
ihnen jede form der intimität aber damit
kam er nicht weit die kranken verliebten
sich hatten kinder gründeten familien
gegen den starken familienzusammenhalt
der griechisch orthodoxen religion kommt
selbst ehlers nicht an außerdem ändern
sich die zeiten
1937 holte eine abordnung aus athen
darunter krankenschwestern die kinder
von der insel sie kamen in ein neues
waisenhaus in der hauptstadt
die bewohner waren einverstanden wie
alle eltern wollten sie nur das beste
für ihre kinder und in der großstadt
wartete ein viel besseres leben auf see
mit richtiger medizinischer versorgung
und größeren möglichkeiten
1941 wenige jahre nach der abreise der
kinder kommt endlich ein heilmittel
gegen lepra auf dem markt
es scheint als hätte das leid ein ende
aber
erst 1948 wurde das medikament auf der
insel verabreicht ein halbes jahr später
waren alle geheilt allerdings hatten
weder die lokalen behörden noch die
anwohner die damit geld verdienten ein
interesse daran die lepra kolonie zu
schließen
von der regierung bekommen die bewohner
keine unterstützung bis 1957 werden sie
auf der insel festgehalten erst dann
wird europas letzte lepra kolonie
geschlossen
bis auf weiteres wird der zutritt
verboten zwei jahre verbringen remondis
und bauen damit die öffentlichkeit über
die vorgänge auf der insel aufzuklären
als born in den 80er jahren nach spina
longa zurückkehrt stellt er fest dass
jemand vor ihm dort war
jemand der versucht hat beweise zu
vernichten
als ich das erste mal hier war waren
alle unterlagen noch da sie waren auf
dem boden der apotheke verstreut
dummerweise habe ich damals nichts
mitgenommen jetzt ist alles verschwunden
es gibt keinerlei dokumente mehr in den
80er jahren wurde alles verbrannt
nach neun jahren
aber es bleibt nicht nur bei der
zerstörung von akten
alles was in den 30er und 40er jahren
gebaut wurde ist zerstört worden von
damals ist überhaupt nichts erhalten
geblieben
born vermutet dass die behörden die
geschichte vertuschen wollten
der startblock die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
sie erfanden zahnen vertreten die fakten
sagten die unwahrheit
ironischerweise haben genau diese
geschichten das interesse an der lepra
insel erst so richtig befeuert heute
zählt sie zu den meistbesuchten
historischen stätten kretas
[Musik]
obwohl wichtige bauwerke zerstört wurden
und beweise vernichtet als biene longa
ein bedeutendes erbe
zu verdanken ist dies vor allem der
arbeit von epaminondas ramon dax
er starb
1978 im athener krankenhaus er war an
herzversagen
bis zum ende hatte er für die rechte der
leprakranken gekämpft ich verlor nicht
nur einen guten freund sondern auch
einen der originellsten und
aufrichtigsten menschen den ich je
getroffen habe
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
vom erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang